hi Samuel Ethier and on this video I
wanted to really explain to you why I
believe that Christmas like this season
the women right now is the number one
best time to invest in property but the
reason that is is because people who are
selling their house right now
properties that are on Rightmove and
that maybe they don't right move a few
weeks or a few months and they're
wanting to sell right now they're
probably feeling really frustrated
because the house came on the market on
October November it's now almost
Christmas and they're thinking ah I do
not want this to drag on to the new year
so at this point in time just before
Christmas when everything is about to
close down it's going to be a week's
more of just having to pay the council
tax on an empty house or weeks more of
them having to live somewhere where they
really don't want to live because
they're really keen to move on they're
frustrated they're motivated when the
sellers are motivated that's the best
time to buy so for that reason it's a
really good time but secondly and this
just blows my mind
oh they're investors right now are all
beginning to wind down for Christmas so
whoa that the harvest is right because
there's so many people really desperate
to sell at this time of year the buyers
are nowhere to be seen because the
buyers and the investors are thinking
I'm gonna really get started in the new
year in the new year everyone's doing
the same thing everyone thinks the same
thing so in January that's when you're
going to stop getting dumped and lots of
people January is okay but December's
better not only are there a lot of
motivated sellers out there but your
competitors all your other investors
where are they then nowhere to be seen
they're skiing or they're there they're
just winding down for Christmas so if
you were planning on winding down for
Christmas if you were thinking okay I'm
gonna wind out for Christmas and then
January I'm really gonna go for it I
would challenge you to change your
perspective and I will give you a
challenge and that is to try and get try
and get one deal in the bag before
Christmas even if it gets to the 22nd
trying get one deal in the bag
go on gumtree go on spare and go on open
and ring agents from from from Rightmove
and just try and bag one day
before Christmas I wish you all the best
of luck let me know how you get on
comment below your action points the
things that you're planning on doing the
activity event take comment below and
that way myself and everyone else will
be able to hold you to account
[Music]